Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to
you by Wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive
in a good way, set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists
from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars
under management. In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions
of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why? Why is
it so popular? Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams, et cetera. And
I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put
you in and if you just want to take their
advice, run with it, do it yourself,
you can do that or as I would,
you can set it and
forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great investing
is a marathon,
not a sprint and little things that you
may or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods
of time. Wealth Front, as I mentioned,
since it's using software
instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low
costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat.
You never pay commissions or
account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free. If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest
a $30,000 account for instance. Now,
normally when I have a
sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and
recommend them. In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because
I'm not allowed to. Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are
not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end
have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront
that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money, at least for me,
uh, in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope
to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free
if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes, fill out their
questionnaire@wealthfront.com
forward slash.
Tim It's fast. It's there's no
downside that I can think of.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create
for you and you can use that information
however you want. wealthfront.com
forward slash. Tim
this episode is brought
to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is a great partner for
creating and growing your business.
It's a one stop shop for
all of your graphic design
needs, whether that's a logo,
website, business card, or anything else.
I used 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times bestseller.
I also use them for banner
ads, illustrations, and other
things. With 99 designs,
designers around the world compete
to create the best design for you.
You give feedback and
then pick your favorite.
You end up happy or you get your
money back. It's very simple.
You can check out a few of my
own designs and those of yours,
meaning Tim Ferriss,
show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners, you guys will get a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
That's 99 designs.com forward
slash. Tim, check it out.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is a special edition where I'm going
to share an excerpt from my favorite
book of all time and in fact
it is a collection of letters,
roughly 2000 years old that I reread
at least once a quarter from Seneca,
the younger,
these are the moral letters to Achilleas
that I've compiled into the town of
Seneca and this particular example is a
letter 17 on philosophy and riches and
Seneca takes a little while with
his preamble to get warmed up,
but my favorite portion begins with,
I might close my letter at this point.
Say you can use that as a bookmark.
I might close my letter at this point
and I was talking to a friend of mine,
uh,
about Seneca.
He's a huge fan also and he said what
I agree with and that is I went back
through my notes and start to compile
a list of the ideas I had the biggest
impact on me letter by letter,
but going through I realized that what
makes Seneca so unique is the common
threads that flow through
different letters.
So it's very hard to just take one
letter although they are valuable.
So I encourage you to check out all
of these letters and you can find
them@ataudible.com
forward slash Tim's books.
It's a three volume set of all of these
letters because I wanted to listen to
them in audio and could not find
it and that's how it got created.
So please enjoy on philosophy and riches
by Seneca and I hope you find it as
valuable as I have.
Let her 17 on philosophy and riches
castaway,
everything of that sort if you are wise,
nay rather that you may be wise strive
toward a sound mind at top speed.
And with your whole strengths.
If any holds you back tired or severance,
but you say,
my estate delays me,
I wished to make such disposition of it
that it may suffice for me when I have
nothing to do last, either poverty
be a burden to me or I myself,
a burden to others.
You do not see him when you say this,
to know the strength and power of
that good which you are considering.
You do indeed grasp the
all important thing,
the great benefit which
philosophy confers,
but you do not yet mr an
accurately its various functions,
nor do you yet know how great is the
help we receive from philosophy in
everything, everywhere, how
to use CICERO's language.
It not only suckers us
in the greatest matters,
but also descends to the smallest.
Take my advice,
call wisdom into consultation.
She will advise you not to
sit forever at your ledger.
Doubtless your object,
what you wish to attain by
such postponement of your
studies is that poverty may
not have to be feared by you,
but what if it is something to be desired
which is of shut off many a man from
the attainment of wisdom.
Poverty is unburdened and free from care.
When the trumpet sounds, the poor man
knows that he is not being attacked.
When there was a cry of fire,
he only seeks a way of escape and
does not ask what he can save.
If the poor man must go to see the
Harvard is not rezoned nor to the wharves
bustle with the retinue of one individual.
No throng of slaves surrounds the poor
man slaves for whose mouths the master
must covered the fertile crops
of regions beyond the sea.
It is easy to fill a few stomachs when
they are well trained and crave nothing
else but to be filled.
Hunger costs,
but little squeamishness costs much
poverty is contented with fulfilling,
pressing needs.
Why then should you reject
philosophy as a comrade?
Even the rich man copies her
ways when he is in his senses.
If you wish to have leisure for your mind,
either be a poor man
or resemble a poor man.
Study cannot be helpful unless you take
pains to live simply and living simply
is voluntary poverty oh way.
Then with all excuses like I have not
yet enough when I have gained the desired
amount.
Then I showed the vote myself wholly to
philosophy and yet this ideal which you
are putting off and placing second
to other interests should be secured.
First of all, you should
begin with it. You retort.
I wish to acquire something to live on.
Yes,
but learn while you are acquiring it
for if anything forbids you to live. No.
Nobody. Nothing for bids
you to die. No Glee.
There is no reason why poverty, you
should call us away from philosophy. No,
nor even actual wand for
when hastening after wisdom.
We must endure even hunger.
Men have endured hunger when there are
towns were besieged and what other reward
for their endurance did they obtain then
that that they did not fall under the
conquerors power.
How much greater is the promise of the
prize of everlasting liberty and the
assurance that we need fear.
Neither God nor man.
Even though we starve,
we must reach that goal.
Armies have endured all manner of want,
have lived on roots,
and have resisted hunger by
means of food to revolting.
To mention all this,
they have suffered to gain a kingdom.
And what is more marvelous to gain a
kingdom that will be you and others will
any man hesitate to endure poverty in
order that he may free his mind from
madness. Therefore, one
should not seek to lay up.
Rich's first one may attain to philosophy.
However,
even without money for
the journey it is indeed.
So after you have come to
possess all other things,
should you then wish to possess wisdom?
Also his philosophy to be
the last requisite in life,
a sort of supplement, nay.
Your plan should be this.
Be a philosopher.
Now,
whether you have anything or
not for if you have anything,
how do you know that you have not too
much already, but if you have nothing,
seek understanding first
before anything else,
but you say,
I shall lack the necessities of life
in the first place.
You cannot lock them because nature
demands but little and the wise man suits
his needs to nature.
But if the utmost pinch of need arrives,
he will quickly take leave of life
and cease being a trouble to himself.
If however his means of
existence are meager and scanty,
he will make the best of them without
being anxious or worried about anything
more than the bare necessities.
He will do justice to his belly and his
shoulders with free and happy spirit.
He will laugh at the bustling of Richmond
and the flurried ways of those who are
hastening after wealth and say why of
your own accord postpone your real life to
the distant future.
Shall you wait for some interest to fall,
do or for some income on your
merchandise or for a place in the,
we'll have some wealthy old man
when you can be rich here in now.
Wisdom offers wealth in ready money and
pays it over to those in whose eyes she
has made wealth superfluous.
These remarks refer to other men.
You are nearer the rich class.
Change the age in which you
live and you have too much,
but in every age,
what is enough remains the same.
I might close my letter at this point
if I had not got you into bad habits.
One cannot greet Parthian royalty without
bringing a gift. And in your case,
I cannot say farewell
without paying a price,
but what of it I showed
borrow from Epicurus?
The acquisition of Rich's has
been for many men, not an end,
but a change of troubles.
I do not wonder for the
fault is not in the wealth,
but in the mind itself that would should
made poverty a burden to us has made
riches also a burden just
as it matters little,
whether you lay a sick man on a wooden
or on a golden bed for whither soever he
be move.
He will carry his malady with him.
So one need not care whether the diseased
mind is bestowed upon riches or upon
poverty.
His malady goes with the man
stairwell.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you'll
get the very next one. And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode
is brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is a great partner for
creating and growing your business.
It's a one stop shop for
all of your graphic design
needs, whether that's a logo,
website,
business card or anything else.
I used 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times best seller.
And they also use them for banner
ads, illustrations. And other things.
With 99 designs.
Designers around the world compete
to create the best design for you.
You give feedback and
then pick your favorite.
You end up happy or you get your
money back. It's very simple.
You can check out a few of my
own designs and those of yours,
meaning Tim Ferriss,
show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners, you guys will get a free
$99 upgrade on your first design.
That's 99 designs.com forward
slash. Tim, check it out.
This episode is brought to
you by Wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive
in a good way, set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists
from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars
under management. In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions
of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why? Why is
it so popular? Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them,
and this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams, et cetera. And
I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it, do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
Here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a
regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods
of time. Wealthfront, as I mentioned,
since it's using software
instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low
costs that were previously completely
impossible.
Right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free. If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest
a $30,000 account for instance. Now,
normally when I have a
sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and
recommend them. In this case
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because
I'm not allowed to. Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are
not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end
have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront
that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money, at least for me,
uh, in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope
to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free
if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes, fill out their
questionnaire@wealthfront.com
forward slash. Tim,
it's fast, it's free. There's no downside
that I can think of. Just take a look,
see what portfolio they
would create for you,
and you can use that
information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash
Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.